the Joe Rogan experience so can I just
your concerns with the protein and just
make sure I'm understanding your
argument protein quantity and protein
quality and within protein quality it
would be the amino acid profile and the
digestibility is that fair though those
are your issues with the consideration
okay
protein is very important we're on the
same page for what we're discussing
right so I I just don't know where and
again not same and it's not possible to
get enough protein quantity right and
quality of and mix of amino acids in if
you're really on it right but here's
well planned just like your any other
diet was well planned I think it's less
it's less likely that you'll get protein
right on a completely vegan diet without
a diet that contains animal protein it's
more complicated it's not it's not more
complicated what it is is if you just
you don't know yeah if you don't know
what you're doing and you've been eating
in a certain way for 30 years and you
slowly take your meat off the plate and
you only eat what was left from the
plate you're gonna have a balance of
knowledge and understanding about that
is pretty low in my experience right no
I agree that's why I agree people need
more resources to make better informed
decisions about their health about their
exercise and so on I agree what's your
position on what he said okay so you
could I just quoting you from last time
now you you really put me through a lot
of hours of extra work now it's gone
from like 3,000 to like 3100 you know
anyway so it was just so much wrong with
what you said that I just had to go in
to eat every single topic but anyway so
three ounces of you said three ounces of
90 percent lean ground beef do you think
the animal fat is not good for you
because all of a sudden now Chris is a
so he's not a protein car what was the
statement in the film film ground be not
retaining debt for protein content no no
no no the statement he felt was the most
common no it's not that's not actually
not 80
anywhere from and grass-fed beef which
is what I advocate okay that was
generally leaner okay great
was specifically talking about protein
cuts no I know that's what we're gonna
go into right okay so listen till mean
ground beef okay so basically what I had
said and I might become of the exact
words that I said but I pretty much do
as I record it a number of times so one
cup of cooked lentils or a peanut butter
sandwich has about as much protein as
three ounces of beef or three large eggs
that was what I said okay I might be off
in a word but that was what I said okay
I said about as much protein okay so you
go on to say three ounces of 90% lean
ground beef well already what you did is
you picked Lina beef but you know even
though you don't advocate for that you
you don't think the animal fat is bad so
what you did is you picked the leanest
beef anyway you say has 24 grams of
protein I'm not sure what your sources
but he does advocate for fed beef
grass-fed beef is leaner so he's talking
about what he does advocate for the
dilip make senses right three ounces of
ground lean meat okay but the thing is
the point in the film most people aren't
saying that most people yeah you were
saying what we said in the film right I
think you're saying regular
asian-american ground beef was much less
about what we're trying to point the
point of this thing was not to say this
is the best foods to read just say like
did you read in comparison the regular
stuff that you eat like a peanut butters
how much people think no protein at all
right I think you know people think that
plants have no protein the first
question you get asked or where do you
get your protein so I said it's got
about as much protein so you so then on
by the way I'd listen to your 30-minute
podcast trying to take down the film
which came out before you came on on
Joe's podcast and you said that you and
you sort of backed this up I don't know
this happened like from one article it
got spread and spread and spread that
someone said you need five tablespoons
of peanut butter to get the same amount
of protein in what world does someone
and you changed your tune a little bit
when you came on the podcast but in when
I may give you another sandwich
I used bread two pieces of bread how
many like you would use to use a bread
and peanut butter sandwich I think that
sort of by definition right that's
pretty much sure so
what you did on your podcast you admit
that a tablespoon of peanut butter is 4
grams right mm-hmm okay
and what is 4 times 5 20 right and and
then by per USDA how much is one piece
of whole wheat bread 4 or 5 depending on
the source you look at I agree how many
pieces of bread - yeah ok
so 5 grams of protein in bread the one
that I actually have a home is 6 grams
but let's take USDA ok
so five five plus five is person 10 plus
20 from the peanut butter is there early
well even on the leanest beef you chose
it was 24 grams why did you say you
needed 5 tablespoons of peanut butter
and I know how it came about because I
think what you do is you take other
people's work like Denise Miller and all
these other people you read their
articles and you take their arguments
because some of the stuff that are on
your site is very reflective of people's
other arguments on other sites so there
was something that started where people
started saying you need 5 tablespoons of
peanut butter and in the first article
it said without the bread now I don't
know why you don't include bread and
when you make a sandwich because I mean
most people do it's not just peanut
butter and I almost bought a peanut
butter sandwich in here today to show
you what two tablespoons of peanut
butter looks like or two and a half
because the one I had I looked at it and
it was surprising like when you actually
measure a real tablespoon it's actually
not that much peanut butter and like so
mine I've fitted out has about like two
and a half tablespoons and two pieces of
bread my bread has like 6 grams butter
all right so my playwrights I'd like 22
grams of protein anyway
red would be more like 2 or 3 grams but
again like we showed a piece of whole
wheat bread on there we're advocating
eating mostly whole foods that's a whole
grain no one is saying we even said in
the film if we want to cherry-pick we
just try and push plants we said white
sugar and flat white flour bad for you
you're associated with weight gain that
carbohydrates from whole food sources
are insulated with better lean body mass
lower body fat percentage and everything
else but anyway so I don't understand
your math what I think it is you took
that article because articles that
spread from that article forgot to put
the bit in parenthesis about without the
two pieces of bread so you take 5
tablespoons of peanut butter at four
grams a piece that's 20 grams right
which is around
what pieces of bread test gratis so why
did 24 grams of your hand-picked lean
beef which you don't even necessarily
like there's no reason that you should
be picking that when that's not what we
showed in the film why are you comparing
24 grams to 30 grams why didn't you say
4 tablespoons of peanut butter fair
enough
Mary now got it wrong again okay so this
is what it's frustrating when I watch
the show because like every five minutes
I'm hearing something that's just
factually incorrect or that's why I hear
that's why I'm here
now again press you to both of you so
can we just look at actual the breakdown
of all these different things so again
the peanut assembly is as 20 to 22 grams
but that's per maybe a little bit more
than some of the other argument was the
quality of the approach we'll get to
that but quantity first so if you go to
bread on slide far oh I don't need to do
this you've agreed you've agreed right
okay so and then tools if you underside
eight oh no I'm sorry what you haven't
agreed on is I'm gonna say two
tablespoons of peanut butter and two
pieces of bread okay fair enough save
for a what I'm just gonna say like the
comparison roughly I need to produce
three three tablespoons sir can you just
three and a half tablespoons of peanut
butter and two pieces of bread no no no
I'm gonna I'm gonna back up what I said
in the film so I let's just go through
the slides quickly if that's okay so
slide five and apologies to all the
listeners who don't get the snare my
slide so tell them to go to youtube yeah
here we go
so what this is USDA so I don't know
what you know numbers from but I went to
the USDA site unfortunately it changed
in October so it's not quite the same as
when we were making the film but anyway
one slice of bread five grams of protein
and you accepted that right mm-hmm okay
good that peanut butter two tablespoons
eight grams you accepted that you expect
that two tablespoons of peanut butter
has 8 grams yeah okay we could have more
I have like more but whatever okay there
we go
so you agree that 18 grams of protein
for the peanut butter that's the
sandwich we showed in the film whole
wheat bread peanut butter okay so the
next slide and again I'm being very
conservative on this like in the mouth
so now I look at lentil
one cup 17.9 grams of protein that is
USDA oh and would you accept that yeah I
haven't looked at this but it's like
yeah on the left side one I accept yes
here is this absolutely okay good but
you accept yesterday when it comes to
this but not in terms of the
recommendations we're talking about yeah
if we're talking about quantity of your
accepted in microwave this is something
that's been clearly measured this is not
something like recommendations okay sure
so but we're on the same page we're
taking this as a soap okay
so now if we go to slide it's nine oh
sorry the one that you just had
so three eggs 18 grams of protein would
you say so far we've got about as much
protein in the peanut butter sandwich
with two tablespoons not the five that
you can like this less I mean 18 is not
24 no no no I'm getting to the beef I'm
saying so far what I have presented just
the two tablespoons of peanut butter and
it's gained 18 I was really conservative
right I could have put moping about I
could have had bread that had more like
the one I don't want in the brand but
you do admit that you can get bread
that's got six grams of protein sure
okay so I'm being really conservative
just sort of prove a point but you so
far we've had a peanut butter sandwich
with only two tablespoons of peanut
butter and we seriously try that arm Jo
like actually measure with a measuring
yeah well I talked about in the podcast
I would probably have about five okay so
anyway I probably would to three large
eggs three large eggs okay so the 18
grams and I'll go to organic this is
organic ground beef standard organic
brown V the ounces so three ounces is
seven point five grams if you want to if
you want to get into it you can get into
later because I just put hundred grams
so I can if you what's the fat
percentage nine point two grams so it's
half no it's no no sorry it's nine point
two grams per hundred grams so you we
had to do the calculation oh but that
mmm okay but this is the regular organic
ground beef in the neighborhood of
and then what to be sex I knew you'd
bring up a grass-fed beef so that I
found the lowest and the highest okay
okay so go to grass-fed beef slide
eleven three ounces this is on the very
low end so this is probably the fattiest
meat but you wouldn't be against animal
fat right not typically depends on the
person and there's I just told you that
person there anyway well Louis fourteen
point four on the highest end I actually
think my number eighteen grams
okay so Pia butter sandwich 18 grams
lentils seventeen point nine can we
round it up yeah three eggs 18 grams
okay three hours of beef 18 grams at
best 90% lean you can have more protein
no doubt so you can find protein that's
got higher I said about I was trying to
show that dispel the myth that you you
know plants have no protein and animal
foods have all this protein so I've just
shown you there now your second point
was that the problem with his second
point was a problem with a peanut butter
sandwich to get 18 grams of protein and
I think this is a fair point you would
have to eat for 410 calories right so if
you go to slide it's actually the more
important point because I'm not
necessarily you know that may not be a
problem for somebody who's training can
we finish so so can you like bring up
slide 15 so you admit that you can get
like a decent man protein your argument
was you can get like percentage so slide
there are lentils for 18 grams of
protein again if you want to check this
calculation and stop at anything I'm
fine I have had this triple checked okay
18 grams of protein 231 calories okay
because you like points now I love that
people like to point out the beef and
then the peanut butter sandwich and try
and compare those even though we were
right on the protein now you're trying
to pick on the calories so you didn't
pick the lentils which have 231 calories
the next one slide six
has was about the same for beef which is
about 210 calories grass-fed beef in the
first instance grass-fed beef in the
first in slide 17 275 calories and that
was on the lot the one that wasn't so
lean and 70% lean beef and I'm just
pointing out there's different Rangers
417 cows for 18 grams of protein right
so fatty meat which you don't think fat
like the animal fat is bad right okay
he's talking about the protein
percentage there was less in my opinion
there was more protein percentage-wise
in my peanut butter sandwich than there
was in the in the green beef and then
the last no not the last one
yeah we could have picked something with
less calories so if we pick tempeh for
example slide 1970 calories so again
would you say but I think his argument
was no the the argument was the quality
of the program there was two part yeah
the part of it was you would have to
consume more calories okay but just
before can I just pray at one point yeah
so the first part was you can't like you
can't there's no a near as much protein
and then there was like always based on
the calories so the percentage of
protein is you would have to have more
calories to get the same amount of
protein which is not perfect we don't
have okay so we made a mistake again it
was not a central part of my art and the
quantity was broken down to two things
you just can't get as much for like you
know song as much in that serving
they're totally wrong you have to have
five tablespoons of peanut butter
totally wrong I agree right thank you
okay and then you also said that you'd
have to have so many calories that you
couldn't get it and you were wrong again
agree for the peanut butter sandwich or
just in general just in general from
plant foods come again slide 20 sweet
potato and leek omelet from Chris's site
where the protein is going so this is
from your site 18 grams of protein 410
calories the funny thing is I typed in
recipes and I think it was either first
or second came up
the all ideas picked the first two
high-protein recipes from your site
because I didn't pick the soup or the
salad so that'd be unfair so I picked
the first couple so sweet potato and
leek omelette cut the protein coming
from eggs 18 grams of protein for neck
eyes do you have an issue with your own
meal no so do you have an issue with the
peanut butter sandwich having 410
calories No okay that wasn't central to
my point there was this the same
quantity which is not would you just
admit it's not quality which is yes
score we're get the Dro in a minute and
I will show that you were wrong again
so Terrell and bacon hash slide 21 18
grams of protein 570 calories if you
want to go to your breakfast of
champions which I thought you know for
athletes slide 22 and by the way I took
your date I didn't at USDA I assumed
that you were not lying so I took the
the totals from the bottom and but I
standardized it for 18 grams of protein
because we're just comparing everything
percentage-wise
688 calories do you think that people
should not eat that meal yeah it depends
on who you're talking about but it's a
low protein right I don't think that
people shouldn't so first of all it's
low protein by like most people
standards but your stands of protein are
much higher so that would be far off so
that would mean to make up for the rest
of the day you would have to have meals
that were like almost just protein or
maybe they'd have to buy the protein
powder from your website in order to
make that up anyway so let's move on to
now the by the way slide 23 largest
study ever done comparing completely
plant-based leaders with extent study
showing plant eaters versus me surveys
five grams a day that was the average
aren't you supposed to have one gram per
body weight per pound of body weight no
upper end for athletes
okay so point eight grams this is this
is how much they're actually getting in
the largest study ever done comparing
plumpie theaters so you can see it's
about the same and actually per pound of
lean body mass fat free mass the vegans
were getting slightly more
cuz they had better body mass index they
were slightly leaner but anyway just
want to say it's roughly similar so your
next argument was the athletes need more
protein it's like right now it wasn't an
argument because you admitted that I
pointed it out in the show yeah so if
you go to slide 20 you know 24 I just
want to point to poking about the amount
that we're actually referring we're
going into the amount now we're still
we're in um yeah we're in a mount for
athletes because his point is like maybe
you can get enough to survive but not to
be an athlete so I'm gonna look I just
think that was this point I think his
point was there's a different
requirement oh no no no no for athletes
yeah survive we won't argue on this
point your point is you need more his
recommendations though what he does is
he pushes them to a really high end that
isn't consensus showing that then trying
to make it out that it'd be harder to
get which we've already shown you can
get enough protein for you know of
course an athlete needs more calories
therefore they get more protein as a
percentage so I just want to texture two
positions on this and then we can see if
you again you don't agree with the
consensus of science so this is the
joint position paper of the Academy of
Nutrition and Dietetics the dietitians
of Canada and the American College of
Sports Medicine so this is for athletes
okay this is just one I'm going to show
you another in a second do you want to
read it out Joker's sure we might get
bored of my voice Teradata see suggest
the dietary protein intake necessary to
support metabolic adaptation repair
remodeling and for protein turnover
generally ranges from one point two to
two point zero grams or kilograms per
day okay and then the next slide Jamie
if you could bring up like I have I
agree with that and have it in my show
on the same page okay supplementation
beyond a total daily protein intake of
1.2 grams kilograms day wait is it wrong
one why where are you reading that from
the big square - no I said 1.6 ok no you
said 1.2 82 grams you read them from the
last thing did I really do that
that's pretty genius that doesn't make
any sense ok so this is what wasn't out
of me right read it again
yeah ok I thought I've read it's 1.6 I
didn't that's what you read your won't
wait six oh maybe I thought I said one
more - to tell no other
Eva's protein supplementation beyond a
total daily protein intake of 1.6 the
squiggle means about oh ok about 1.6
grams kilograms a day during our ETS
resistance exercise training provided no
further benefit on gains in muscle mass
or strength and these are like really
highly and and if you look at the and
I'll I'm so I'm not a kilogram but
kilograms to pounds of body weight your
pointer to point to so we're 1.6 grams
so it's less its point seven two seven
two seven two grams per pound so you're
looking at about three-quarters of a
gram per pound recommended anything over
that provided no games I want to clarify
so you can see the the two-phase
breakpoint analysis on the top right
this chart yes okay so you can see that
you can see as the chart goes up and
then it flattens out there was no
further gains in fat free mass which is
the y-axis and after one point six
however there's a constant got a
confidence interval like how confident
are they that these findings are correct
and it was a very wide competent
interval so it actually took it there
was six grams either side so it's
actually up to 2.2 and down as low as
one mm so it's one to two point to the
other one the Academy nutrition
Nutrition and Dietetics and the Academy
of Sports Medicine - - - so the widest
range is 1 to 2 point 2 so some so you
think that this like recommendation
that's a standard thing that you hear in
a gym one gram per pound of but it's
probably just a friend so two point two
point two grams on the upper end the two
point two grams per per kilogram of body
weight per day is one gram per pound of
body so no doubt and this is what you're
talking about certain athletes like
bodybuilders trend athletes but a
confidence interval means to apply to
everybody some people could actually
build optimum and this is about
optimally building muscle as fast as
possible right and some people could do
a 1 gram something you might do point to
but like readily it would like 1.6 1.8
like the scientific consensus that and
you said you agree with these ranges of
the science and there's some evidence
suggesting that higher amounts may be
beneficial so if you go to or Jamie if
you search for examined calm
how much protein do you need there's an
article there and examine calm is a do
you know about about them said I know
you're on a panel of scientists or a
group of scientists a group of
scientists right not not the American
Sports Medicine the indicator an
indicator amino acid oxidation method
which was newer if you scroll down Jamie
to the optimal daily protein intake for
athletes and similarly active adults or
if you just click on that you see in
that paragraph is and athletes found
different numbers because four of the
forty nine studies in the meta-analysis
meta-analysis that had that range lower
range were conducted in people with
resistance training experience the other
forty five were newbies ILO different
numbers female athletes required one
point four to one point seven meal
endurance two point one and two point
seven a mature male bodybuilders this
seems the same point this is the average
amount of protease probably get some
higher one maximize lean mass is about
1.6 grams per kilogram it's the same
exact your it's like totally accepted in
sports world like whatever it's also
says some people need upwards of two
point two grams per kilogram for those
interested in comprehensive breakdown it
provides another link range we're not
far off on this
it says regular training some male
endurance athletes require two point one
two two point seven grams per kilogram
so that's the high range yeah and so and
you could you do say something about two
point eight is three point three and one
and remember in one study you pointed
out that was just doesn't actually help
you build more muscle mass but if you're
trying to lean out yeah and also I think
some of the studies that you've looked
at that look at like there's one at two
point three I've actually got it on my
computer I don't have in my slides but
there's one at two point one two three
point three you've got a Moute there's
two things about that one it's when
you're in a caloric deficit because of
gluconeogenesis you'd pull some of the
protein and you crit you know you use
some of the energy so there's less
protein less for building
if you're a bodybuilder cutting for
competition trying to get down like 4 or
5 percent and your protein requirements
go up above that still more range
because you're basically using so you're
in Clark deficits you're using some work
for fuel and that's also the case with
those carnivore people and a lot of keto
people as well right yeah and they
probably adapt some because like normal
people you can actually only during
exercise you can only get 10% of your
energy from the oxidation of protein
into glucose but so the where we going
so that the 2.3 to 3.1 by the way it's
one in caloric deficit and it's two
based on fat free mass qualifications
it's not based on total body weight
which is what all the recommendations
are on so the the 2.3 to 3.1 in some of
these studies if you did like okay if
someone's 15% body fat right I would
bring it down right there wouldn't be
2.3 to 3.1 based on the moneyman so if
you're 200 pounds and you've got 20%
body fat
you're only weigh 160 pounds for this
calculation got it anyway where we are
so you'd like to talk about the IAR into
into these recommendations and if you
like to slide 102 Jeremy how am i doing
by the way defending in the film
excellent you really doing really well
good not bad for a dumb old UFC fighter
right you're not that old
41 how much proteins can the body use in
a single meal for muscle building
implications for daily protein
distribution showed up were of see one
of 2.2 grams 4 kilograms a day and
cohort of young male bodybuilders all of
the method of assessment indicator amino
acid oxidation technique used in this
study has not received universal
acceptance for determining optimal
proteins or armaments so it's in that
same range so I'm not yeah but I mean
the couple things I'm not trying to
point out that your ILO is off I'm
saying if you want to take your iro the
indicator amino acid oxidation index if
you want to use that then the upper
confidence so is still 2.2 so the
scientific consensus I just want to make
it very clear that you threw out a bunch
of these numbers on high protein making
out the vegans couldn't hit that level
first of all I've shown that foods can
get that I've shown the vegans can get
sufficient protein and I've shown that
I've shown the levels that
the scientific consensus on the protein
ranges for athletes and not inside the
consensus with these 3.3 but even if
they were there's no reason you couldn't
get it on a plant-based I didn't argue
that everyone should be eating three
point three grams now you may doubt that
vegans can get enough protein and you
were wrong I didn't say they couldn't
get enough I said that it's less likely
that they will get it's not like some of
those recipes on your website the
beginning less
[Applause]